even though it's already three hours
long not all of Avengers endgame made it
to the screen some of the deleted scenes
are probably best left on the cutting
room floor while others might have made
the movie even better from goji berries
to a tearful farewell here are the
scenes you didn't get to see one of the
six deleted Avengers endgame scenes is
ordinary but unintentionally hilarious
for a few reasons
titled goji berries the moment takes us
inside Pepper Potts and Tony Stark's
lakeside cabin where they're living in
married bliss and discussing fairly
unexcited things like alpacas and
berries first of all Gerald is our
backup he's eating my go geez okay
they're gonna be nice and salary notes
the scene is extra humorous considering
Paltrow's real-life love of health
wellness and cooking as some Marvel fans
may know Paltrow owns the natural health
company goop which sells clothes shoes
supplements and yes even goji berries
another deleted Avengers and game scene
references the events at the end of
Captain America the First Avenger
bearing the title bombs on board the
sequence features James Rhodey Rhodes
and Steve Rogers running through what
happened to the tesseract after Katt
crashed a Hydra aircraft in the First
Avenger the tesseract which the
present-day Avengers were looking to
find as part of their time heist mission
fell out of the plane and sink to the
bottom of the ocean during the crash why
did you have to crash the plane anyway
bombs on board so Rhodey asks the
obvious question and you couldn't have
jumped out of the plane before you
crashed it seriously
why didn't he jump out that's one moment
where Rogers could take a good hard look
at his past self and say
that is America's answer a silly and
unfinished scene cut from the theatrical
version of Avengers endgame futures
Rocket Raccoon sitting with surviving
members of the avengers crew at the
team's headquarters gathered around a
table the heroes watched some footage
from the Avengers fight against the
Chitauri in the 2012 battle of New York
as seen in the first Avengers film
rocket asks how long Earth's Mightiest
Heroes fought and Black Widow responds
about - 2 or 3 hours the Starkey racoon
is shocked that the Avengers spent that
much time in battle with the aliens the
Chitauri the suckiest Army in the galaxy
why don't you just blow up the
mothership rocket gets a good laugh out
of how inept the Avengers were but of
course Tony Stark always gets the last
laugh in another deleted scene that
still has some early CGI rocket and Thor
in his fat door state are back in the
year 2013 lurking through the halls of
the Asgardian palace the two were trying
to determine which path to take to avoid
the Dark Elves attack and retrieve the
reality stone to take back to 2023
unfortunately the god of thunder is of
little help when Rocket asks which way
to go after urinating off the side of a
palace wall to the floor below Thor says
that he's not coping well with being
back in Asgard during the time in which
he witnessed so much death he admits he
doesn't know the correct path to safety
but rocket doesn't appreciate the
honesty
you used to frickin live it for 1500
years not forever I think we had that we
are so so dead the scenes between Tony
Stark and his distant father Howard
Stark were some of the most heartwarming
ones an Avengers end game however a
small moment left out of the final film
would have inspired even more fuzzy
feelings as the father-son duo are
walking through the 1970s shield base
while discussing the fears that come
with first-time fatherhood and the
importance of leaving a legacy Howard
gives Tony an offer that must have been
hard to refuse mattoni doesn't miss a
bead with his reply
it's work I work for me putz I'm a
little tied up and future Supreme you
get it because he's from the future
anyway
it's a brief little moment but we'll
take all the stark family bonding we can
get thank you
damn to this country while the rest of
the deleted Avengers endgame scenes are
all under a minute long the final one
comes in at almost two minutes the
heaviest sequence both in terms of
emotion and length the Avengers take a
nice scene happens immediately after
Tony Stark's sacrifices his life in the
battle against Thanos as Tony slips away
Pepper Potts kisses his cheek while the
Avengers look on and realized the weight
of what just happened
Hawkeye drops to one knee and places his
head against his hand to honor the
Fallen Avenger who started the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this sparks a chain
reaction and one by one the rest of the
heroes kneel and respect we even catch a
shot of the 2014 Gamora looking on
almost contemplating kneeling before
turning and walking away maybe she's
going to hang out with Deadpool in the
non kneeling Clubhouse yeah that's
really hard on your knees totally
impractical they all do it this deleted
scene is impactful but let's be honest
the theatrical scene was already
heartbreaking enough adding this into
the mix would have left everyone full-on
sobbing into their popcorn check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superhero films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
you